The old woman and the chicken
The narrator of this story is Karunakar Baidha.
In one country there was an old lady named Teej Sarai, who was a beggar and had no wife
He went into the jungle and searched for a village where he was helpless. It was very difficult for him to feed himself.
One day, while he was searching for firewood in the forest, he saw a chicken in the bushes.
Said Banaya had a flower for the chicken, he took the flower home and kept it in a big jar.
A few days later, he found a nest for the chickens in the place where he had kept the flowers.
When he went there, he saw two chicken chicks, which he thought were very good. The old woman did not eat the chicks herself, and her brother also gathered and ate them.
One day that Kukhura went to the flowerbed and flowers started flowing. The old lady took the Kukhura and asked him to give her some money. I told her somewhere that she would take me along with her.
Hearing the chicken speak like a manchuk, the old woman was shocked and with great difficulty saved herself and gave the one penny she had saved.
The shopkeeper, the shopkeeper, gave me one paisa worth of rice as soon as I saw it, and the shopkeeper said, "How many tears does one paisa worth of rice make?"
And the chicken said, "I put as much rice as I can in my ear canal." And the shopkeeper said, "How many ears can be in a small ear canal?" He said, "I put rice in the chicken's ear." The psychiatrist went to the chicken's ear, but the shopkeeper's rice was too small.
This is your money, now go and get some rice for me.
I have become like this because I didn't take my money earlier
A little rice was spilled and the dust flew away.
The house was built with the help of a dog.
Grandma, grandma, eat something.
Bhudi le pani ukkhra le banig raste garn
And take a knife and eat it with your ears,
The little girl's hands were covered with rice.
The chicken flew again and reached the pasture of the flying flower.
Tesla Pani cheated him by taking chamal from him
Put the old lady in the house and put a sprinkling of water on her
Take a penny with three chickens.
Salt, oil, spices, etc., were collected in green piles
And with the help of the shepherd, she and the old woman and the dog built a large house like a palace.
That old lady was as beautiful as a queen.
Wealth and possessions were not lacking for any king.
One day, the chicken decided to marry the daughter of the king of that country.
Every now and then they found a bee lice in the nest.
And those ants made
Kuphraap maa vya the world doesn't hear us
Kukhra Dai Kukhra Dai where are you going
And let's make it with a straw.
Marry the daughter of the king of lice.
And the bees made
I know that you take me with you
Which one of you will be working on?
And I took the water from the knife and started keeping it inside my ears
As he went, he made a big pond.
And that pool left him.
Where are you going, dog?
And the chicken became the king's son and scattered the flock.
And the water from the pond became the mud that flows through the river.
Maybe I can be of some use to you.
And the chicken also took the water from the pond in its beak.
Tish Daura also asked the same question.
And again the chicken became the king's treasure, scattering it.
And the fire of wood was made, you also made me go with you.
Sayth mother, can you do some work like this
And the chicken became a chicken, so you gave me a chicken, sister.
And the fire of the wood made me talk, "What did you say?"
Even the old man put his ear to the pillow and took it.
One day you will be caught in the royal court
And flew away and sat on a branch of a tree.
That day, Rajgo was about to be separated from his family.
All of you have seen your good moves and happiness
At that moment, the rooster crowed and became a rooster.
O gatekeeper, I have come to leave the kingdom and join the Sangha.
Bring the king and send him the news
First of all, the doorkeeper is the one who listens to the kukhra
But later the country started chasing some soldiers with stray dogs.
And the chicken also with great agility
Mauri brothers, the soldiers would have eaten everyone's heads
It was only made by a handful of bees.
The soldiers, while roasting, took a bite.
The poor people, crying out in fear, came to the king to request everything.
The king also thought it was wonderful and sent for the dog to call him.
Then you should go to your home with a big gift
Finally, the righteous king did not ride on horseback.
Kukhra bhabhi hai your income is bad
The king saw that the snake was very respectable and he drank it.
Your Majesty, I have come to ask you to marry Azura's daughter.
Please marry me to Azura's daughter.
And the king said to the warrior Iktam
Then I will go and make this girl with me and I will marry my most beautiful daughter
This is my wish, I have to say this, I want to live your life
And why is the number of chickens decreasing?
And the dog also addressed the fire and ordered it to burn down the king's palace.
The king had to take the Kukhra and the lamp was in his court, and he had to bowl in front of him.
All the brothers started running everywhere, making a lot of noise.
The king made millions of attempts to put out the fire.
Then the people around him became angry and started shouting
Finally, the king gave up and promised to marry his daughter to the dog.
The three-legged dog gave the order for water to extinguish the fire.
I answered the question, and first I stood before Ramnarayan's court with my sister in law.
And the king took great pomp and show and married his daughter to Kukhra.
Ani Kukhra Princess Baba Laskar accompanied by music came to her home
Don't be surprised when you get a princess daughter-in-law.
On that day, after seeing many servants and brothers, they went to Haruli Ghariyar and settled there happily.